Andrew first of all what did madmen and
that Don Draper character do for your
industry it got us talked about got the
industry talked about not necessarily
positively but it got the industry
talked about and that's usually a good
thing but I think one thing it made us
really understand the creativity behind
it how emotion ties so much into what
they do and essentially what you knew
yeah emotion emotion is what drives
behavior and we've we've just done quite
a lot of work on this because there was
a guy called Peter field who did a
survey or did a big study in the UK on
brands that had one effectiveness awards
so we knew they'd worked and and then
looked to see if they'd also one
creative rewards to see if there was a
correlation between the two and there
was but while he was doing that he also
noticed that brands that had used
emotional advertising tended to have
disproportionately high effects whether
you look at the impact on the profit the
business or the brand metrics and
emotional it's super sexy it's totally
upsetting because that's kind of what we
know Don Draper for really pushing that
envelope right and when you dig into the
science of it right at the heart of it
it's it's understanding that whilst we
would like to think we all behave like
Spock we're actually a lot more like
Homer Simpson how our behaviors are
driven much more by primitive urges and
instincts than they are by thinking
things through rationally and a lot of
work has been done on this and there are
two molecules that get stimulated by
different experiences that really matter
one is dopamine which is the molecule of
confidence of lust the thrills and
spills you get buckets of it if you take
cocaine you get little squirts of it if
you get three fruits lined up in a game
of candy crush that's a highly highly
addictive molecule if you can stimulate
the production of that and attach that
feeling to a brand that will in turn
drive behavior and the other one is is a
molecule called obviously Tosun not to
be confused with oxy cotton also highly
addictive equally addictive and that's
the that's the molecule of love of
belonging
security of trust and again if you can
stimulate the production of that
molecule attach it to a particular brand
then the next time the consumer sees
their brand it triggers retrieval of
that wonderful feeling and they may act
now advertising has by this point become
this scientific on a regular basis how
often do you take an ad and study human
response to that ad ad that's that's
that deep a level where you're looking
at the production of sort of naturally
produced human con yeah so we usually
you're testing ads before you make them
so you can't actually do this test you
can't test for oxytocin and and dopamine
without a finished work so what we do
what we did was we had this as the
hypothesis we thought we'd tested and
prove it and we took five brands and we
took for each brand two pieces of work
one which we knew had worked reasonably
well one which we knew had worked
exceptionally well and then we had a lab
at USC test respondents for their
production of oxytocin and dopamine
while they viewed each of these pieces
of work and in every single case every
single case the production of oxytocin
and dopamine action accurately predicted
the sales outcome from those pieces of
work
why is your new Snickers campaign doing
so well because that produces a lot of
dopamine why because it's got lots of
twists and turns and thrills so it walk
us through the campaign so the the the
the campaign is a combination of what
I'd call high impact I reach events like
running a commercial in the Super Bowl
with them you know where we take take
the mickey out of the Brady Bunch with
Steve Buscemi and and Danny Fredo
it has a central idea you'll not you
when you're hungry that is a really
powerful plot so we combine those big
moments where you you get all of the
surprises as you work through the
30-second commercial with atomized
storytelling in all of the places that
consumers spend the rest of
their time you recreate that experience
you're not you when you're hungry
all through consumers lives all their
touch points for example on Google
search we found out that and you will
notice when you type in words you often
misspelled them yes
so we found that what the 10,000 most
frequently misspelled words are and then
the 250,000 versions of those misspelled
words and then we paid to buy the
misspelled words of course you don't
have to pay very much because nobody
wants to pay to buy misspelled words and
then went through and then when people
typed in a misspelled word it up would
come a thing that says you can't spell
right when you're hungry you'll note you
grab a Snickers how cool is that that is
search engine optimization that's for
sure
we did a fabulous thing on tinder which
is you don't know what to well familiar
with tendon yeah so people make bad
choices lots of bad choices on tinder so
we created profiles of characters that
had little things wrong with them and if
you if you swiped right on tinder for
one of these bad profiles up would pop a
message that says and you make great
eyeballs and 11 fingers nobody lists
that on tinder amazing